John Wilkes Booth assassinated Abraham
Lincoln in his diary as you write in
your book he wrote about Lincoln our
country owed all her troubles to him and
God simply made me the instrument of his
punishment the country is not what it
was
uh what was the idea of the country that
John Wilkes Booth believed in you talked
about this country that just constantly
being repeated in his writing for John
Wilkes Booth and many other uh people
who were close to the southern part of
the country in the Confederacy they
believe the country should be a
democracy for white people abounded
democracy and uh Booth was horrified and
we have to empathize with it not
sympathize but recognize how how strange
it seemed to him that all of a sudden
those who were slaves were now Soldiers
with guns
and he was particularly offended when he
saw in Washington DC a group of
African-American Union Soldiers holding
Southern prisoners of War
and the world was turned upside down for
him democracy for him he believed in
democracy but democracy for white people
and that justified uh mistreating black
people for him
it's a country means uh white white
people yeah and and I don't think it's
that different from
um and white Christians white Christians
yes yeah he was not arguing for Jewish
emancipation either
um I I I don't think that's really
different from what we've seen in the
20th century for people who justify
ethnic cleansing or genocide
uh let's go to the you know the extreme
example of Hitler again uh that we've
talked about before
his view was actually he he claimed he
wanted a democracy for Germany he wanted
a democracy of the right Germans and he
wanted those who he saw infecting and
mongolizing the society out that's in
essence what John Wilkes Booth thought
the scary thing is those kinds of ideas
you can put a pretty face on them like
you don't have to use and maybe Hitler
didn't until the war started or even
parts of the war make it so clear that
you just want the certain kind of
Germans that have made Germany a great
nation to be the people that are running
that nation and other people who are not
truly interested in it don't hold the
interest of the country at heart like
they should go elsewhere where they can
flourish also is wonderful but like the
good Germans uh they've built all these
amazing things which should give them
the power and not to the others and you
can put a bunch of Flowery language
around that precisely it's the argument
that's made all the time today against
immigration
that the wrong people are coming into
our society it's ironic because it's
often made by those who themselves are
immigrants
history teaches us that those who have
arrived as immigrants are no more likely
to like those who come in fact they
might be against the next group for just
this reason because they think they're
the right group